tonight new information about a deadly
shooting that happened thanksgiving
morning in
various locations in and around
henderson including at a 7-eleven
on lake mead parkway and center street
that's where joe mohler now joins us
live and joe the arrest report shows
that the victims
were just innocent bystanders
the people involved allegedly shot at
nearly a dozen people that morning the
7-eleven store behind us here was turned
into a crime scene on thanksgiving day a
total of four people were shot at this
location
one of them did die now tonight memorial
continues to grow i'll give you a live
look
kevin mendiola junior who was 22 years
old was
shot and killed outside of this 7-eleven
store that day
now take a look at this video this is a
from the scene thursday in the police
report we learned there were
three people who allegedly shot at
random people around the area
they were identified by police as sean
and christopher mcdonnell
and kaylee lewis police say they were in
a black car and pulled up next to
several drivers and opened fire that
morning
after shooting at several drivers the
three eventually came to the store where
they shot four people
mendiola was killed and the others were
taken to a hospital after the shooting
here police say they drove down lake
mead parkway and shot someone else in a
car they went to the hospital as well
later that day the trio was allegedly
involved in an
officer-involved shooting in arizona
where they were taken into custody
now back on here live another look at
this memorial police were able to match
descriptions from witnesses to security
cameras
police say they believe christopher
mcdonald is the one who is responsible
for mandiola's death
he is now facing an open murder charge
with a deadly weapon
reporting live in henderson joe moore 8
news now